Luke transportation right now is is one
part of the energy sector where a single
source currently oil dominates and and
again Neil showed that in his
presentation and really right for right
now has a pretty strong lock not not a
lock type and a strong lock on usage in
the US for example I think and you'll
correct me if this is office about
ninety-five percent of the
transportation comes from oil so can you
tell us how you view this changing
through time and what some of the
drivers might be that would cause that
to change Thanks great thank you David
it's a great pleasure for me to be here
it's an honor to be on this panel and
thanks very much to the climate and
energy institute for the invitation you
know I was was was nice to learn of our
connection my connection with the
background that neil has and in the
sense that we both served in the Navy
one of the things that you've learned
very quickly as an officer standing
watch on the bridge is that when you
come across a tanker or a cargo ship out
on the ocean that ship is not going to
move its course for you you're going to
move for it and you know that the you
know the the cruiser that I was on
typical Navy ships were manned up to to
go to volatile areas and to change our
way of doing business very quickly you
know we may have on the ship I was on we
had 600 crew members including the
officers at anchor or a cargo ship might
have 15 or a handful and so I bring that
up from the standpoint that the u.s.
obviously is a in a sense of the energy
world we're kind of a tanker you know
we're a huge consumer
china is obviously coming up in passing
us in ways but we can't keep the course
steady and expect everyone to move
around us we need to move more like a
Navy ship and take advantage of the
innovation that we can put forth and
help that guide sort of the direction
that we take going forward I'm going to
focus on a United States perspective
mainly because that's the area that I
work in but because of the opportunity
for us to take really a strong
leadership role as they mentioned you
can't you can't talk about can't talk
about the transportation sector and not
talking about oil you know because it is
basically the source of fuel for the
transportation sector in the US the
transportation sector is responsible for
about seventy percent of the consumption
of oil and if you look at oil as a
primary energy source it is the number
one source of greenhouse gas emissions
in the United States from a climate
perspective why do we why do I work on
vehicles and fuels in the transportation
sector well the transportation sector is
it contributes about a third of our
pollution climate pollution nationally
and about eighty percent of that
Transportation Secretary missions comes
from vehicles on our roads so
understandably they need to be an area
focus as well I wanted to quickly sort
of paint the situation of where we are
and some ideas some points ahead for
what what the future may look like
according to some forecasts and so the
blue box here represents kind of what
are expected emissions for the US
transportation sector from a co2
perspective if you are just thinking
about what the policies are that are in
place right now and if you look in a
2030 timeframe the red represents kind
of the trajectory that we were on the
red dotted line and you can see that we
were headed towards higher missions
and the green represents really a
trajectory that we need to be on to meet
an eighty percent reduction in
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050
relative to 2005 so the fact that we're
below the red means that we've made some
progress and we should we should
recognize that and think about what it
is that's gotten us there but of course
the fact that we're still above the
green means we have quite a bit of work
to do so when we talk about you know
sort of how we reduce emissions and oil
using the transportation sector we focus
on traditionally it's a solution stool
built 13 legs those three legs are
basically how much fuel our vehicles use
per mile that they drive or their
efficiency it's how much do we actually
have a demand for driving or our vehicle
miles traveled and third it's what we
put in what's the carbon intensity of
the fuel that we put in so I'm going to
touch on each of those those very
briefly here we have in the first area
efficiency we have a great story
actually here in the US and this has
been a large chunk of where our mission
reductions have come from this chart
here is showing the progressions from
2007 out to the present monthly tabs on
it of what the new vehicles fuel
efficiency of the new vehicle fleet is
produced in the United States now this
just shows the upward trend over the
last you know since 2007 over the last
seven years or so but if you were to
take this trend back what you would see
is that actually it was just this long
flat period for four decades where we
didn't increase fuel efficiency
standards at all and actually our fuel
efficiency as a new vehicle fuel
efficiency was was going down because of
the shift towards higher fuel use in in
the basically the shift towards SUVs so
this has been a huge policy success it's
been really a landmark program of the
Obama
to put these standards in place set over
two stages in 2010 and 2012 but I wanna
to dance point about the role of the
state's this was leading into this was
that are a lot of states were using
authority under the Clean Air Act to set
greenhouse gas emission standards for
vehicles leading in to this federal
process and was really a helpful push in
that Connecticut being one of the states
that had adopted california's program
and so the states as a laboratory and as
a push to get federal policy is
continues to be very important this
isn't happening just in cars and light
trucks but it's also in happening in the
heavy-duty sector and right now the
administration is looking at the second
phase of the fuel efficiency standards
for heavy-duty trucks and working on
that right now and so that's going to be
a major factor one of the maid pieces
that's going to help us close that gap
between where we are and where we need
to be even in a 2030 timeframe the VMT
picture for decades VMT or vehicle miles
traveled has been on a very rapid rise
in the United States but what we've seen
recently is that actually questions
being asked by a lot of researchers is
whether or not we've sort of peaked are
we on the way down actually and once
that one some folks are thinking that on
a per capita basis people are going to
actually not drive more but we actually
may start be continued to see a decline
in per capita and with that decline in
per capita we could see a leveling off
of emissions in total demand for driving
and you know this is due to a lot of
different factors economics demographics
you know no longer is it that everyone
has to drive somewhere to meet up when
when everyone now has a smart phone in
their pocket they can do you know can
talk to each other via the web so you
know a lot of factors are at play here
but it's something that's become real a
real
thing to study in terms of where the
even the energy information
administration is now focused on this
and that what they've looked at is that
even in one of their low VMT scenarios
this could reduce petroleum consumption
in the transportation sector by like
eighteen percent just this reduced
demand and driving where historically
this was just something that was up
going up up up and up now those are
pretty positive stories let's talk about
the fuel sector now this is a less
positive story or let's say it's an
opportunity an area for a lot of
opportunity so this this graphic here is
emphasizing the fact that we have as we
continue to have demand for petroleum
we're going after harder to reach
sources and we're going after higher
carbon intensity sources so in this case
it's the tar sands from Canada if that
becomes a large portion of the fuel mix
that doesn't that that pushes our
transportation sector carbon emissions
in the upward direction so basically
we're counteracting all these things
that we're doing with vehicle efficiency
or a shift towards electric vehicles
we're counteracting that if we move
towards more high carbon intensive fuels
this graphic is focused on highlighting
kind of the regional impact here in in
Connecticut and surrounding states we
get about half of our fuel supply from
pipeline that comes from the Gulf and
refineries from those Gulf refineries
and also we have some refineries in our
region so if tar sands gets to the Gulf
we'll get part of that it's also as more
tar sands moves by rail or pipelines get
reverse that's being talked about in
Canada then we're going to get more tar
sands into our regional refineries
that's going to increase the carbon
footprint of the fuel supply that we use
just to give a sense of what that means
we have this really landmark
cap-and-trade system or not cap and
trade but a relatively kappa
great system on our electricity sector
in the region called the Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative over five
years that's projected to reduce
emissions by on the order of 11 million
metric tons if we hit what could be
projected to be eighteen percent of our
fuel supply from tar sands in this
region in one year that'll increase our
emissions profile by ten million metric
tons it would offset essentially what
we're trying to achieve in five years
within the electrics electricity sector
so what they're one of the policy levers
that could be they could really help us
drive forth towards innovation in the
clean vehicle clean fuel sector is
something called a clean fuel standard
and what that does is it has a two-fold
effect it basically says the carbon
intensity of the fuel supply needs to go
down over time and it sets a standard a
performance standard just like fuel
efficiency standards for cars this would
be a carbon intensity standard for fuel
if you set a trajectory of where that
has to go down that shifts investment
away from things like carbon intensive
fuels and towards things like
electricity for vehicles potentially non
feud fuel biomass for biofuels hydrogen
powered electric bus here those examples
are things where the you're creating a
market so again you're not dependent on
a lot of federal or I mean public money
but you're creating a market that Spurs
that innovation and I'm happy to talk
more about that as we get to the Q&A
finally we have examples of where we
really need to be to meet our long-term
climate and energy goals in the
transportation sector we need to shift
to electric drive vehicles the reason
for that is that electric drives gives
you the best efficiency but also the
fuel there in this case plug-in electric
vehicles using the electricity from the
grid it's the one fuel that's actually
getting cleaner
time we're not going to meet our
long-term climate goals unless we clean
up both the electricity sector and the
transportation sector so let's do that
hand in hand let's get the vehicles out
there that I can actually use the
cleaner electricity as we move in that
direction these are vehicles that are
cleaner today but there will only get
cleaner over time and you can't say that
for any of the fossil fuel directly you
know liquid fuels and I you know this
slide also points to a lot of the things
that Karen started to raise and that
there's a there's a great interaction
between electric vehicles and where the
electric power grid is going and
basically when you talk about electric
storage technology every one of these
cars has the potential to be an electric
storage technology or to be a mobile
on-demand load that really helps manage
the intermittency of renewable power so
hopefully that's a good lead-in for the
discussion thanks very much for your
attention and I look forward to your
questions
you